y aquí tenemos la gráfica de x que
escribimos así y nos preguntan cuál es
el residuo cuando p de x es dividido
entre x 3 pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo y nos dicen que la respuesta
debe ser un número entero y seguramente
suponen que esto requiere el teorema del
residuo polinomio lo que nos dice es que
el residuo de pd x dividido entre x 3
independientemente de cuál sea digamos
que el resultado es igual acá este valor
de acá es el resultado de evaluar el
polinomio con aquel valor de x que hace
que la expresión x + 3 sea igual a 0 o
qué pasaría si evaluamos el polinomio en
x igual a menos 3 aquí hay que ser
cuidadosos porque la gente a veces se
confunde porque ve un 3 positivo y
quiere evaluar el polinomio con 3
positivo para encontrar el residuo y
esto no es así si vemos un 3 positivo
aquí hay que evaluar con un 3 negativo
acá pero esto debe ser igual acá así que
cuál es el residuo cuando p de x es
dividido entre x + 3
a que es igual este polinomio evaluado
en menos 3
pd - 3 es igual a 2 negativo así que el
residuo es igual a menos 2 hagamos más
ejemplos aquí nos dicen que px es igual
a todo esto dónde acá es un entero
desconocido que interesante pd x
dividido entre x 2 tiene residuo 1 cuál
es el valor de cada pausa en de nuevo el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo
bueno este segundo enunciado px dividido
entre x 2 tiene residuo 1 nos dice que p
no es de 2 negativo sino pd 2 positivo
es decir la expresión que hace que esto
sea igual a 0 nos dice que pd 2 es igual
a 1 y luego usamos esta información para
calcular a que es igual pd 2 es igual a
2 a la cuarta potencia menos 2 por 2 a
la tercera potencia más k por 2 al
cuadrado menos 11 todo esto que es igual
a pd 2 va a ser igual a 12 a la cuarta
es 16 menos 2 x 2 a la tercer
es 16 más k por 2 al cuadrado es 4 k
menos 11 es igual a 1 estas se cancelan
y ahora sumamos 11 en ambos lados de
esta ecuación y obtenemos 4 k es igual a
12 dividimos ambos lados entre 4 y queda
que k es igual a 3 y terminamos hagamos
otro ejemplo de hecho hagamos 2 más
porque esto es divertido la siguiente
pregunta nos dice p de x es un polinomio
y nos dan los residuos de pd x dividido
entre varias expresiones al final nos
dicen encuentra los siguientes valores
de px
pd - 4 y p de 1 pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo muy bien pd - 4 es
igual al residuo cuando p de x es
dividido entre que quizás se vean
tentados a decir x 4 pero están tratando
de engañarlos
este es el residuo cuando p de x es
dividido entre x + 4 y por aquí nos
dicen que puede x dividido entre x + 4
tiene un residuo de tres así que ponemos
el 3
y de forma similar pd1 es el residuo de
px dividido entre no x 1 sino de x1 y
vemos que p de x dividido entre x menos
uno tiene un residuo igual a cero
hagamos un último ejemplo nuevamente nos
dicen que pd x es un polinomio y nos dan
algunos valores de x nos preguntan cuál
es el residuo cuando p de x es dividido
entre x menos 3 pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo ya hemos hecho esto
varias veces el residuo de px entre x
menos 3 va a ser igual a no espere menos
3 sino igual a pd3 positivo cualquiera
que sea el valor que haga esto igual a
cero vemos que puede 3 positivo es igual
a 5 y de forma similar vaya qué
interesante cual es el residuo cuando p
de x se divide entre x y quizás se estén
preguntando a que es igual esto pero si
reescribo esto y en lugar de x escribo
que es dividido entre x + 0 entonces
dirán
entiendo o si escribo que se divide
entre x0 también dirán a ya entiendo
esto va a ser igual a peu de cero no
importa si es positivo o negativo y nos
dicen que p de 0 es igual a menos 1 y
con esto terminamos